غاليه شاكر من ابرز النجوم الشباب الذين
نالوا اعجاب الشباب في السنوات الاخيره
تعزف على الجيتار وتشارك يومياتها
ونجاحاتها مع الجمهور الان تشارك في
مبادره جديده تهدف لبث الهدوء والشعور
بالسلام في نفوس الاطفال في اوقات النوم
من خلال اغاني النوم الاطفال او التهويدات
هذه المبادره طورها فريق مختص من علماء
واطباء امريكيين متخصصين بالاعصاب
وتطبيقات العلاج بالموسيقى في جامعه
نيويورك وجامعه ستانفورد لمساعده الاطفال
الذين تعرضوا للكوارث والازمات وما اجمل
ان تكون هذه التهويدات الموجهه للاطفال
بصوت الفنانه وكاتبه لاغاني السوريه غاليه
الشاكر التي كتبت وسجلت النسخه العربيه من
هذا المشروع
برويل
محروم
وفي الاستوديو تنورنا الفنان الموسيقيه
غاليه شاكر غاليه اهلا بك مساء الخير
رمضان كريم رمضان كريم شكرا طب دبدة
بالحديث عن هذه المبادره وما الهدف منها
هاي المبادره عملناها مع بيبي شوب واسمها
مبادره من نوع اخر لانه اول مره يعني
بنحكي عن مواضيع صايره مثلا يونس بطريقه
موسيقيه
او صاير بس هالمره
لذيذ بغنيه عملناها طيب هذا بخصوص الحمله
ككل طب انت كغاليه شخصيا شو اللي خلاك انك
تكوني جزء من هذه الحمله هلا انا اكيد
كسوريات الموضوع كتير هامني دغري ما ترددت
ابدا بس اخترت لولو باي مو غنيه ثانيه
لانه اكثر العالمي متاثره بهذا الشيء هم
الاطفال فقلنا الشيء الوحيد اللي بنقدر
نهديه للاطفال هو التوهيده يعني هي
الاغنيه البسيطه اللي
مثل
فقلنا خلص هي هذا هو المشروع وكتبنا
الكلام هذا الاساس واللحم كان كثير بسيط
وكثير كيوت اي حدا بقدر اتفضلي
غمض عيونك
عيونك الحلوين
حتى تشوف نجوم
لعيونك مضويين
غمض عيونك عيونك الحلوين
[موسيقى]
حتى تشوف نشوف
لعيونك نضويه
خلي نجوم اتقول لك اني بحبك انا كثير
عم استنى يجيب بكرا حتى تصير كبير
يعني يسلم هالصوت وزي ما بيقولوا وقعتي
نصف عمري للذي يجعل طفلا باكيا يضحك يعني
هذا احلى اشي فيه دايما نزرع في الاطفال
الحب والحنان والاهتمام كمان نحن معهم جزء
من اي حمله طبعا
طيب اليوم غاليه كمان احنا رح نحكي عنك
كغاليه الفنانه وفي الموسيقى الى جانب هذه
الحملات التوعويه ليش اخترتي هذا الطريق
وهل بتعتبري نفسك مختلفه عن غيرك في مجال
اليوم
هلا انا
[موسيقى]
كيف تعملين ان يكون اثر هذه الاغاني سواء
على الاطفال كهويده سلام يسمح الكل
[موسيقى]
مره ثانيه طيب الاثر اللي تتمنيه يكون
لهذه الاغاني
تهويدات السنه
[موسيقى]
اهي
حتى تشوف العصفوره رفع
غمض عيونك
عيونك الحلوين
حتى تشوف العصفوره
ورفعتها ومبسوطين خلي العصفوره الله بحبك
انا كثير
عم استنى اجي بكره حتى تصير كبير
هالمقطع تاني بنغنية المقطع طب شو برايك
مثلا اهميه انه يصير في عنا عمل مشترك
يعني بنتحدث عن المفوضيه اللي تعنى بشؤون
اللاجئين للامم المتحده وايضا يونيسف كل
هذه الجهات تعمل وايضا للمؤثرين العرب
وغيرهم بظن هذا الشيء اللي عملوه يعني راح
يكون تاثير كبير لانه متماثل
بهذه الرساله بالموسيقى بشكل عام بالعاده
بيكون خلص شي محكي وبنشوف العالم ما
بفكروا فيه السوشيال ميديا اما الاغنيه
كانت يعني شي كتير كبير بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
طيب غاليه يعني انا كثير صوتك كله احساس
وشجر حتى كل العالم هون اللي عم يسمعوا
منطربين بس حابين نسمع شغله غير تهويده شو
بتحبي تسمعينا كمان
اغنيه اسمها عبالي عبالي اوك عبالك شو
بالاول ان شاء الله يكونوا الاطفال
[موسيقى]
بتتذكر لما كنا اصحاب
لما كنا صار تحت نجوم الليل
[موسيقى]
كنا قرب
نوضي كل الوقت
على درج البيت
ترجع ليهم يا الله شو عبالي
عيد اللي كان لولايلي من الليالي
ترجع الايام يا الله شو عبالي
عيد اللي كان لوليلي من الليالي
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات